attorneys for a disgraced movie mogul
Harvey Weinstein will call witnesses
today to try to discredit evidence he
engaged in a pattern of criminal sexual
behavior Weinstein is on trial for
allegedly raping one woman and
assaulting another he's always
maintained what he did was consensual
Harvey Weinstein ignored cameras as he
walked out of court Thursday after his
attorneys began their defense trying to
convince the jury he is innocent of rape
and sexual assault it follows more than
two weeks of testimony by six women all
of whom claimed Weinstein sexually
assaulted them yesterday actors Lauren
young concluded her testimony she says
in 2013 Weinstein invited her to his
hotel room stripped off his clothes
pulled down her dress and groped her the
trial started with Sopranos actress
Annabella she ora he claimed Weinstein
raped her at her apartment in the early
90s the defense tried to poke holes into
your story yesterday film producer Paul
feldsher testified she hora told him
about an encounter with Weinstein but
that there was nothing that she told him
that was quote shocking my understanding
was that she fooled around with him but
prosecutors aim to show bias pointing to
felcher 'he's long friendship with
Weinstein including that Weinstein once
paid feldsher $60,000 as a consultant on
a movie attorney Gloria Allred
represents several of Weinstein's
alleged victims the prosecutor sliced
and diced him until there was next to
nothing left of him it's one thing to be
able to defend against one accuser maybe
even two but really difficult if not
almost impossible to defend against six
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clemens
says the defense will now have to sow
doubt into the stories of all six women
they have to use experts to both show
that memory could be false but also that
these women have a reason to accuse the
way that they did the defense plans on
calling a memory expert in others over
the next few days if convicted Weinstein
could spend the rest of his life in
prison and remembered
just this case in New York but he's also
facing charges in Los Angeles a case
after this about a week to go in this
trial drinkin yeah about a week from
what we understand so we'll see what
happens